docteur car le vice président de
l'association des médecins
microbiologiste-infectiologue du québec
que bonsoir dr weill est ce que vous
avez aimé recevoir une date que le
sommet va arriver autour du 18 avril au
québec qu'est ce que vous en pensez
d'abord on avait les gens parlaient déjà
d'une date du 18 19 avril donc il n'y a
pas eu de secret à l'intérieur de ça je
pense qu'il faut faire très très
attention sur les modèles mathématiques
parce qu'ils ont tous une chose en
commun ils ont tous jour ils vont
toujours se tromper un petit peu donc il
ya une espèce de course modèles
mathématiques de tout le monde dont tout
le monde a voulu pour toutes sortes de
raisons y compris des raisons de
transparence et c'est correct ainsi
vouloir avoir un modèle mathématique de
la part des différents gouvernements
donc c'est des modèles mathématiques il
ya des erreurs quand on met des données
ici mais je suis très loin d'être un
mathématicien
mais quand vous mettez de mauvaises de
données haut débit vous allez avoir de
mauvais résultats il ya des choses que
vous pouvez pas calculer vous pouvez pas
calculer l'impact de la distanciation
social du lavage des mains de gens qui
portent des masques dont il emporte moi
donc il ya tellement de facteurs mais la
densité de la population que c'est
impossible à mettre dans un modèle donc
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que c'est une
estimation potentiel de ce qui risque
d'arriver au québec et c'est un modèle
qui a ses faiblesses et ses forces mais
qui nous dit qu'ils te qu'on est obligé
de faire pour voir combien on va
utiliser deux lignes combien auraient
utilisé des respirateurs et juste pour
vous donner un exemple précis
aujourd'hui aux etats-unis ils ont
révisé leurs propres modèles
en dix ans on aura beau on aura
probablement moins d'un an on aura
probablement besoin de moins de lui il y
en aura probablement besoin d'au moins
deux ventilateurs donc ce qu'il faut
dire c'est un modèle où on a un mauvais
scénario
un bon scénario et que la tendance
actuelle semble montrer qu'au québec on
a un scénario raisonnablement optimiste
à la condition qu'on continue de faire
ce qu'on continue terre je vais vous
montrer ce qu'on montrait le tableau des
des soins intensifs hospitalisé aux
soins intensifs en jaune c'est le réel
c'est le réel donc ce qui est arrivé
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et on voit qu'on est
même en deçà du scénario le plus
optimiste à dire qu'ils resserrent va au
portugal ce qui veut dire que pour les
hospitalisés
si on l'a avoué vraiment d'un
dérèglement qu'on ne voit pas arriver
d'une indiscipline généralisée lors
d'une nuit magique on va quand même
rester en deçà des capacités
hospitalières mais pas encore la faire
attention avec ces données là parce
qu'il faudrait beaucoup plus se préparer
par exemple à l'ontario l'alberta et la
colombie britannique
d'autres provinces canadiennes qui nous
ressemblent beaucoup plus en nombre de
lits par capita en noms de nick soin par
capita aussi en termes de pratiques vous
savez il ya des pays où on n'admet plus
facilement les gens à l'hôpital que dans
d'autres en amérique du nord
habituellement on a tendance à moins de
mettre les gens à l'hôpital qu'en europe
on a tendance les soins intensifs il ya
des gens qui sont plus frileux dans
certains pays pour les envoyer aux soins
intensifs mais ce que ça montre c'est
juste que ya tellement de paramètres
aussi difficile mais d'un autre côté ça
montre qu actuellement notre capacité au
de soins intensifs au québec est loin
d'être débordé donc il faut être prudent
mais on est plutôt sur une bonne part
dans il faut qu'on a dit ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas il faut arrêter tout
ce qu'on fait actuellement docteur un
abajo dieu du de l'om est me disais tout
à l'heure quand on voir quand les
économies vont repartir il faut qu elle
repartit qu'il faut qu'elle repart
tranquillement parce que si on repart
trouvait effectivement on va devoir
imposer un deuxième confinement pis là
ça va être très très compliqué à vendre
ça la population dont vous êtes d'accord
aussi que quelque part mi mai quand on
va repartir par exemple ici il faut il
faut y aller mollo où il va falloir y
aller par vagues il va falloir avoir
plusieurs stratégies par exemple il va
falloir peut-être envoyer les plus
jeunes son marché du travail
vous savez on est dans la phase
défensive actuellement de ce virus là
c'est à dire c'est nous qui subissons le
virus il va falloir se préparer à un
moment donné à l'est dans la phase
offensive c'est à dire de nous qui
allons se débarrasser du virus de
différentes façons donc il va falloir
s'équiper savoir que les hôpitaux auront
plus de résilience de profondeur et
éventuellement commencé à retourner
travailler en disant qu' on renvoie
travail et probablement les plus jeunes
parce qu'on sait que feu en moins le
risque de compliquer donc ils vont
peut-être faire d infection
asymptomatique qui vont peut-être être
un peu malade
iront certainement pas souvent soins
intensifs va falloir faire attention ils
contaminent pas des plus âgés les gens
qui sont sans humour ont promis donc il
va falloir si vous voulez remettre
tranquillement les gens dans la machine
mais tant qu'on aura pas de vaccins
évidemment va vivre avec cette menace là
autour de nous et il faudra être plus
fort je vous dis je vous donne quelques
questions docteur quand même sur
l'origine de ça la question numéro 1 va
peut-être faire sourire les gens mais
quand même j'habite dans les cantons de
l'est ce à chaque été il ya des chauves
souris qu'une niche et volent tout près
de notre maison
ge est il un risque accru d'attraper la
comète 19 non pas du tout par contre
votre grand risque c'est la rage lors
les chauves souris au québec le gros
problème c'est la rage n'est pas le
coville 19 alors c'est plutôt ça qu'il
faut faire attention
très bien et puis je saute à la question
numéro 3 2 et les ailes à 11 ans
pourquoi la cause et de 10,9 fait plus
de morts que le strass alors qu'ils font
tous les deux partie de la même famille
de virus
alors c'est ce qu'on explique souvent
c'est à dire que pour un virus il ya
deux choix il peut être méchant c'est à
dire virulent où il peut se transmettre
facilement et l'exemple classique c'est
le rhume le rhume ça se transmet très
facilement mais c'est pas très dangereux
alors le sera ce un virus qui était très
dangereux avec un taux de mortalité très
élevé dans ces virus la tendance à se
transmettre - parce que justement c'est
un virus vous expliquer ne peut pas se
multiplier tout seul donc il a besoin
d'utiliser l'appareil de cellules de
multiplication d'un autre mais si tu es
tout ses hôtes c'est à dire s'il était
trop méchant il commettrait un peu à un
suicide
donc il ya un équilibre entre un strass
un qu'on va appeler qui était beaucoup
plus méchant mais beaucoup moins
transmissible par son ajustement il été
trop méchant dr weiss
merci beaucoup bonne fin de journée on
se revoit on se reparle très bientôt
merci docteur hockey au revoir